i'll tell you what banks is obsessed
banks is my my three-year-old she's
obsessed with my music hillary duff has
a fan in daughter banks but it's not
exactly what dreams are made of
i'm fully thirteen again and i'm like
god why that's so embarrassing yeah the
mom of three gets real in a new
interview with variety about how her
middle child loves listening to her
iconic tunes even when hillary really
doesn't want to it's very embarrassing
to roll through my neighborhood and
she's like yowder yowder just wants it
louder we're right there with you banks
and i'm blasting like so yesterday and
songs off of dignity and it it's
horrifying it's horrifying and she's
just be like i want sparks i want sparks
[Music]
i'm like oh god every time we get in the
car it's so embarrassing while hill may
not be too excited about blasting her
own hits around town she is all about
pleasing her fans well at least her
littlest one you'll do anything to shut
up a three-year-old who repeats herself
like she's wasted and you're just like
okay
we're doing it and banks isn't the only
one loving a hillary duff music
throwback the 34 year old singer's
classics are having a moment and it's
all thanks to tick-tock
yeah remember this performance by
hillary on the tonight show with jay
leno back in the day well it became a
trend on tick tock and after getting
tagged in countless recreations hillary
broke out the with love choreo herself
[Music]
and the hill duff nostalgia doesn't stop
there back in october joe jonas and
sophie turner grabbed the internet's
attention with these uncanny lizzie
mcguire costumes
their throwback moment caught hillary's
eye who reacted in the comments with i'm
screaming so do you sit down with your
kids and watch lizzie mcfire though
no
i i have we've watched the movie and
while hillary's kiddos may not yet have
the same respect for lizzie as her peers
she does bond with her eldest luca over
a different pop culture guilty pleasure
we watched the bachelor last night
because i was on on monday yes we need
to talk about that i do sometimes watch
the bachelor and sometimes i let him
watch the bachelorette but he actually
loves it
and when he it came on when i finally
came on last night it was so cute he
just yelled out
and i was sitting right there with him
watching but he went mom
and i was like oh my god
yes i'm right here
it was very very cute of course fans can
check out hillary on tv too she's now
starring in how i met your father on
hulu today is the first chapter of my
next great love story and the actress
tells e.t she may soon take a page from
her character's book and tell some
stories of her own to luca i can't wait
to like maybe drink a little bit too
much wine and have him be like you're
annoying me right now get to the chase
you know like that's it's really sweet
i'm already there a little bit like he's
nine and so he's starting to like hear
more and more
and but you know it's gonna be different
when he's 23. it's just
i just closed my eyes and i'm like i'm
gonna be there and this makes me smile